im hafen von split lässt kapitän ivan
radeljic zwei dutzend urlauber von bord
es sind seine ersten kunden seit zehn
monaten auf dem weg zum heimathafen
räumen sie auf routine war noch nie so
schön 95 prozent weniger gäste hatte er
im letzten jahr es geht wieder los meint
er
delta variante seit kurzem kommen die
anfragen für diesen sommer meist last
minute oder besser gesagt last second
booking heute aber ist ein wendepunkt
ist sich ivan sicher heute morgen wurde
er vater
[Musik]
ein sohn ist geboren singen sie als der
heimathafen in sicht kommt das muss
gefeiert wird
die bahn plant nachwuchs auch für seine
flotte
es ist brauch dass der sohn kapitän wird
wie sein vater so wie ich meinem vater
nach gefolgt sind ja so läuft das hier
hin
es ist eine zeit der hoffnung und der
zweifel in kroatien split braucht
touristen aber es ist weit weg
die meisten kamen mit dem flugzeug nun
ist das für viele abschreckend um über 8
prozent brach im letzten jahr kroatiens
wirtschaft ein
tourismus ist der motor corona droht
weiter nördlich von hier steigen die
zahlen leicht data ist im anmarsch große
gruppen sieht man kann manche genießen
gerade das wie dino und gabel weile
warten
also wir sind mit dem auto länger
gefahren
die autotour war wunderschön und mal was
anderes hat allerdings zwei tage
gedauert und sonst fliegen wir corona
hat ihren urlaub verändert sie haben
eine wohnung gekauft sie wollen es nun
sesshafter verlässlicher mann dankbar
dass er die ganze welt gesehen und jetzt
wollen wir das erwägen die domizil haben
bei dann wollen wir auch gewisse zeit im
jahr verbringen wo es schön warm ist der
trend zum individuellen urlaub ist für
tomislav kovacevic
[Musik]
er hat kurz vor der krise 200.000 euro
in diesem top komfort bus investiert
amerikanische und asiatische gruppen
fuhr damit zuletzt chinesin im januar
der chinesische reiseleiter sagte zum
abschied bis bald wir haben da ein
kleines virus es kann sein dass es ein
paar monate dauert aber dann komme ich
wieder nach europa seit 19 monaten macht
tomislav nur leerfahrten um seine busse
zu checken er hat sich hoch gerackert
zehn jahre auf seinen ersten bus gespart
nun hat er vier und muss sie ungeschützt
abstellen wo es nichts kostet ich habe
kein geld mehr das ich sparen kann
ich habe einfach gar kein geld mehr ich
muss so parken bankrotten paradies droht
nicht nur ihm erzählt tomislav in dieser
saison wird es wohl nichts mit
gruppenreisen umsatz ersatz oder
ähnliche hilfen bekommen private
busunternehmen nicht
sie haben protest fahrten gemacht zeigt
er mir und etliche eingaben bei der
regierung
30 busunternehmen sind schon bankrott
es ist sehr traurig wir sind ein junges
land ein schönes land wir geben alles
für gut und tourismus ich möchte der
regierung fragen wenn die touristen im
nächsten jahr zurückkommen wer soll sie
dann herumfahren vielleicht kann ich
noch ein oder zwei monate in meinem haus
bleiben auch wir fragten bei der
regierung nach keine antwort
wir nehmen die fähre nach korsika
hundert kilometer weiter südlich
nur ein paar slowenische wanderer und
einheimische sind an bord
cordula ist besonders bei briten populär
und die kämpfen jetzt mit der delta
variante
[Musik]
das hotel hat zurzeit nur ein gast vor
17 jahren kam er nach kurzem zurück zu
den wurzeln
seine vorfahren waren arme bootsbauer
sie wanderten aus nach südafrika enkel
zlatko kam zurück denn der tourismus
hier war die neue goldmine dank an
corona ich hoffe dass england und die
usa ihre leute bald wieder in die finger
lassen
[Musik]
das sind meine hauptkunden zurzeit sind
ja alle besorgt wegen der nächsten welle
also kommen die gäste wahrscheinlich
erst spät und wenn nicht wenn nicht
die insel ist praktisch corona frei und
ihre schönheit muss bald wieder ziehen
sagt zlatko denn er hat kurz vor der
krise eine million euro in ein zweites
haus gesteckt reporterin macht er sich
gedanken über ein zweites standbein
unabhängig vom tourismus das hat er auch
von seinen nachbarn gelernt erzählt er
denn diesen vorsichtiger mit
investitionen sie haben kriege erlebt
und sozialismus
keiner steht zu tief drin wie sie haben
hier turbulente zeiten erlebt man hat
ihnen eigentum weggenommen um es
arbeitern zu geben und die leute sind
skeptisch sich zu sehr auf das
kapitalistische modell einzulassen
aber ich gehe weiter voran
[Gelächter]
es gibt grund zur zuversicht die
kreuzfahrtschiffe sind wieder da
sie legen an end to trocknet corona
konform geringer belegt
alle gäste getestet oder geimpft mann
geht von bord im wabbel konzept die
gruppen bleiben unter sich das ehepaar
mesmer ist begeistert toll dabei nicht
mal wieder darf beim landgang in
dubrovnik dürfen sie aber nur wenig die
gruppe zieht am café von pavicevic
vorbei welcome in dubrovnik
dass babbel konzept erlaubt keinen
kontakt mit einheimischen keinen kaffee
oder shop besucht klar macht das traurig
aber was kann man tun
die regeln sind nun mal so und man muss
glücklich sein dass sie überhaupt kommen
solche bilder waren vor corinna
undenkbar
dubrovnik litern oberthur wissen bis zu
10.000 gäste tätig heute ist drängelei
verpönt die vier kreuzfahrer das
ausscheren aus der gruppe sogar verboten
fremdenführerin sonja der bus muss
darauf achten das fernsehteam will
wissen ob ihr diszipliniert sein
ja das sind sie hören auf ihre
fremdenführerin
ich bin ihre mama sie sind die kinder
und den verräterischen gruppen aufkleber
haben diese belgier versteckt sie sind
sauer wenn man in einen laden geht und
erwischt wird kann es sein dass sie
einen nicht mehr aufs schiff lassen
extreme einschränkungen bei gleichem
preis beschweren sie sich auch auf dem
schiff nervt es gibt vier whirlpools und
1500 leute und es ist nur eine person
pro whirlpool erlaubt sie können sich
ausrechnen wie oft ein jeder baden kann
da muss man zwei jahre rum fahren bis
jeder dran war
für sie geht es weiter gen norden für
uns nach süden in montenegro sind die
schiffe kleiner der tourismus auch dabei
hat das land einiges zu bieten
helga haag und i got you babe sorgen vor
fünf jahren nach montenegro
das frankfurter auto ist ein deutsches
überbleibsel raus aus der tretmühle
wollten sie hier sei der alltag bunter
die existenz grünen nur ganz
ferienwohnungsvermieter ist auch ohne
corona ein kulturelles abenteuer
da hilft es dass igor als serbischer
schwabe die landessprache spricht und
felder als sächsische frohnatur über
unterschiede was nur lachen kann
ja ich denke einen hand von der sprache
ist es schon wesentlich einfacher für
mich das einzige was mir nicht gefällt
sind die ganzen plastiktüten deswegen
kommen wir immer mit unserem korb mit
butt butt butt unsere leute total
deutsch also ich merke auch seitdem ich
in montenegro bin wie deutsche ich
tatsächlich will der lock down the heart
die boca bay noch nie so leer gewesen so
wissen
nun ist gelockert die korona zahlen sind
auf einen jahrestiefstand delta ist kein
thema sie machen ihr boot bereit heute
kommt die erste gruppe seit langem 25
prozent der einheimischen leben vom
tourismus
auch muschelfischer daniel dobra stevic
kann nun endlich wieder größere
portionen verkaufen hilfe vom staat gab
es fast nicht ich habe eine frau
tatsächlich in der straße angehalten und
hat mehr oder weniger mit weinenden
augen mich nach dem job gefragt egal
nach dem rasenmähen wäschewaschen sehen
wir machen und da sieht man einfach nur
wie es das land getroffen hat auch wir
hatten ja auch existenzängste muss man
natürlich auch sagen nur wir hatten
wirklich das glück dass wir wirklich
gäste hatten die uns auch selbst in
dieser zeit in der korona zeit auch die
stange gehalten haben gäste zeiten ohne
ihre ferienwohnungen zu nutzen erzählt
helga oder gaben zinslose kredite helga
und igor wissen dass sie glück hatten
viele montenegrinische nachbarn hatten
es nicht nach coruna sei ihr
handgemachter tourismus sogar stärker
gefragt meinen sie damit ist mehr
gemeint als ego sagt erfolge dann habe
ich selber geschossen
wer heute eine so lange reise macht der
wir genau wissen was und wer ihn am ende
empfängt sagen sie also das würde ich
mit einem klaren ja beantworten dass es
vertrauen gerade letztes jahr das a und
o war dass die gäste zu uns gekommen
sind ist wird sich verstärken ich glaube
dass die leute durch die krise die wir
jetzt gegangen sind eigentlich immer
mehr nach genau diesem suchen ohne
vertrauen keine entspannung meinen auch
die gäste am abend es sind
klassenkameraden von igor aus welt sein
es ist für sie die erste weite reise
seit langem sie kamen nur weil sie
erkennen
sie alle hoffen dass reisen wieder
möglich ist das delta das licht wieder
ausbremst das wirkt wie ein zeichen dass
ich da über montenegro ein
hoffnungsvoller regengebiet zeigt